I'm Michael Walzer and I am a professor
now emeritus at the Institute for
Advanced Study in Princeton professor of
social science
well the analogy that I drew in the
essay was with political
constitutionalism because I think that
that the competition for power has
similarly corrosive effects as the
competition for for wealth but we've
we've taken into account the corrosive
effects of the competition for power
that's the point of limited government
that's the point of democratic
constitutionalism the F the idea is to
set limits on what people can do in
pursuit of power and on what they can do
with the power that they win and I would
do exactly those same things in the
economy I would set limits on what
people can do in the pursuit of wealth
now to some extent we do that we we
prohibit theft and extortion but
obviously there are forms of market
behavior which don't come under the
definition of theft or extortion which
nonetheless are brutal in their effects
on other on other people false
advertising promises that that financial
brokers make to to the people they whose
money they claim to be managing and I
would regulate that and then I would set
limits on on the extent of wealth and
then we have to set limits on what money
can buy in the same way that we set
limits on what power can do in the world
and the limits on what money could buy
that means that people should not be
able to buy university put Ivy League
university places for their children
they should not be able to buy expensive
medical care that isn't available to
body else they should not be able to buy
justice or in the courts or or political
influence and if all they could buy with
their money was rare books or fancy
gourmet dinners then money would be
harmless and that's what money should be
we should we should take the sting out
of money and that would that's just the
way we take this thing out of power a
president cannot use his power for
personal aggrandizement he could not use
his power to get his son into an Ivy
League college he cannot use his power
to get the Supreme Court to make the
decisions he wants them to make we have
we have separation of powers we have
limited government we have Congress can
override a veto we have all kinds of
mechanisms to set limits on what
politicians can do we need to set limits
on what enormous ly wealthy people can
do limits of essentially the same kind
I don't accept the notion that greed on
Wall Street the the exemplary form of
the corrosion of moral character caused
this crisis because greed always exists
on Wall Street greed is what makes the
capitalist system go as Adam Smith
taught us everybody pursues personal
gain and somehow the invisible hand
makes it all work out for the best
but the invisible hand doesn't do that
as we know what is necessary is a
visible a visible hand and that's the
visible hand of the of the state
regulating market behavior taking into
account the corrosive effects of
competition and the cause of this crisis
is the failure of governmental
regulation because that's what's new and
recent whereas greed has is a permanent
feature and the crisis is obviously not
a permanent feature of of the capitalist
economy
I think people people are ambitious and
people are greedy in very different ways
and in very to very different degrees
democratic politics depends on the
ambition of of some people to win an
office and iose and the capitalist
system so we are told even by the it's
defenders depends on the propensity to
gain wealth to search to seek for wealth
so those are just facts about the world
and we don't harness them but we we
accommodate them within what
constitutional structures and yes in a
certain sense we need them I remember
back in the 1950s I remember being told
by an old older friend and political
mentor that Ed Lee Stevenson was a very
good man but he didn't want to win and
therefore he wouldn't win and we needed
somebody who wanted to win and I guess a
corporation where some entrepreneur has
a new idea which may or may not bring
pleasure or comfort to millions of
people that corporation wants somebody
to drive that idea as hard as as he can
and the motive for doing that may be
fame and glory but it might for many
people be wealth
so yes it's not entirely wrong to say
that we we use those
driving forces but mostly we try to
control them Crooked Timber Isaiah
Berlin's line I think from yes we
are Crooked Timber but most people I
think do the decent thing when they can
when they're not under terrible pressure
under terrible threat and a few people
do the decent thing even when they are
under terrible threat as we see in the
history of Nazism end of Stalinism and
but those people are philosophers call
it super auditory they are above and
beyond the normal level of expected
behavior but I think people are people
are good if you put them in
circumstances that are not frightening
and and if you don't expose them to
threats of brutality and destitution
you